foreign
[Music]
to talk to you today about our use of
different DNA sequencing Technologies to
assemble and characterize metagenomic
samples
so and even though I'm giving you this
presentation today this was a major
collaborative effort I'd like to even
though I will acknowledge more members
of our Consortium later I'd like to give
specific thanks and gratitude towards
our collaborators at UC Davis
Misha komogorov and papa pesta as well
as our collaborators at Pac bio
specifically Elizabeth saying and also
Tim Smith at USDA mark
I've sectioned my talk into three
distinct topics the first I wanted to
give some background information on what
a metagenome is and what its use is in
the research Community then I'd like to
talk a little bit about the complexities
of assembling the metagenome and the
limitations imposed by DNA sequencing
Technologies
finally I'd like to talk about a big
breakthrough that I feel will change the
field of metagenomic sequencing and
assembly and to conclude my talk at the
end
but the most important thing is uh for
this talks purpose what is a metagenome
and I will be using the following
definition which is the totality of
microbial genomes derived from in this
case a tissue
and I'd like to State more specifically
that when I'm talking about a metagenome
and a meta genome assembly I'm talking
about the DNA sequence within the sample
and even more specifically just for
clarity and illustrative purposes just
the DNA within single celled microscopic
organisms this is not always the case
there's some multicellular organisms
within metagenomes but their means of
classification and annotation are still
novel
the metagenome has major impacts on a
diverse array of different subjects in
the field of biology much of this is
derived from experiments we've done or
notobiotic animals these are animals
that are rare in abiotic environments
and are deprived of their innate
commensal microbial communities we found
that such individuals particularly mice
have smaller large intestines and can
often be malnourished if given standard
diets due to lack of vitamins and
coenzymes
in addition metagenomes have been found
to have play a major role in vaccine
efficacy in Mass models it turns out
that the certain cells resurface
receptors in the gut need to be
stimulated by the commensal microbial
Community to elicit immune responses
against certain pathogens when given a
vaccine
and finally I'd like to point out that
even though a lot of our data comes from
these sorts of model organisms
metagenome complexity and influences
exist across the entire spectrum of
environmental and living species there
are many symbians and competitors that
will actually cause changes in growth of
many different species based on the
presence and or absence
but even though the metagenome can be
important in these fields of study it's
a generally temporal and
diverse set of organisms and this causes
a great deal of complexity in confusion
in terms of how it can be assessed
for example there can be different
sampling biases when you're trying to
assess the metagenome community based on
the presence of different organisms that
are with calcitriated DNA extraction or
sequencing
and in addition to that emitted genome
is often a snapshot in time when it is
sampled and much of this has to do with
the fact that certain organisms can be
present in one stage or condition and
absent in another and this can vary in
the order of seconds or minutes or hours
in addition to that these are living
organisms that reproduce and as such
sustained mutations as they pass down
their genetic information and so this
sort of variation needs to be carefully
distinguished and characterized in any
metagenomic sampling
there are some different ways in which
we can characterize the effects of
metagenomes on systems and environments
that probably the simplest and most
straightforward would be to measure both
inputs and outputs from metabolic
standpoint however this is this sort of
treats the metagum as a black box and
distinguishing characteristics of the
metagenome are lost in this translation
one method that is the gold standard is
to use amplicon sequence analysis where
you target conserved genes that should
be present in all lineages amplify them
and identify variance this one common
Gene that's targeted for this sort of
analysis is the 16s subunit ribosomal uh
sequence and the reason for this is
because it's prevalent in almost all
prokaryotes and has very well conserved
regions flanked by variable regions that
sustain mutation
and the final and most in-depth is to
use whole genome sequencing and assembly
in contrast to the aforementioned
amplicon sequence experiment this is
more expensive and requires a lot more
computational analysis however it gives
a better picture of all of the genomic
DNA in the system as opposed to the use
of a single copy Gene and extrapolation
based on variant analysis
even though 16s amplicon sequencing is
the gold standard and often is used
statistically to claim High degrees of
completeness there are some environments
in which we have limited knowledge of
the system in order to classify variance
and distinguished lineages
and one such example taken from a whole
genome shotgun sequence analysis in the
rumen published by Stuart at all in 2017
they attempted to take genome sequence
reads and classify them based on genomic
databases
when they used all previous assembled
microbial genomes including all of
refseq in order to classify the origin
of the Reeds from their study at Max
they had a 30 classification rate which
meant that 70 percent of the weeds had
never been seen before in previously
used databases
it was only when they took those reads
and generated the assemblies themselves
for a sample specific assembly that they
had higher classification rates and were
able to assign those reads to different
lineages
however DNA sequencing analysis is
commonly contrasted against the activity
of solving a jigsaw puzzle and as you
can imagine the old trick that's
commonly given as advice for starting
jigsaw puzzles where you actually take a
look at the box art it's not applicable
here we don't know what the composition
of the community is
however
we are able to rely on computational
algorithms called genome assembly
algorithms to use different segments of
DNA in order to reduce the complexity
and try to find a better resolution and
more details of a picture of the
metagenome
typically these data sets consist of
hundreds of millions of pieces so it
would be impossible for you to manually
solve a metagenome puzzle within the
span of your life
and to give more clarity and terminology
uh one the algorithms that we use are
termed assembly algorithms and you can
think of the most simple type sort of
algorithm and most intuitive as being
the comparison and overlap of DNA
segments this type of DNA assembly
algorithm is called consensus overlap
and the resulting sequence is called a
contig or a contiguous stretch of DNA
a slightly less intuitive method is the
use of assembly graphs where you take
the DNA sequence of each read and
decompose them into a graph that can be
fed forward and improved by the addition
of other reads this is the algorithm
that's used by the metafly assembler
that we use in our proof of principle
later
and finally you cannot typically
generate a single microbial genome
assembly from a contact
so we use long range information in
order to try to take a bunch of concaves
and place them together in what we
assume is the genome sequence of an
organism from the community and special
information is required for this
including the use of linkage information
that I'll talk about later
however as I mentioned DNA sequence
cannot typically be used to form an
entire contact and much of this is
because of errors or issues with the
complexity of the genome for example the
read length needs to be larger than
repetitive sequence and because the
presence of orthologists or highly
similar genes in different organisms you
need to have highly accurate reads in
order to identify and distinguish them
we found this in our recent study in the
rumen using a comparison of long and
short DNA sequencing Technologies and
even taken from the same sample at the
same time a completely different picture
was found in terms of both the Reeds
themselves on the left of the diagram
and the assembled con takes on the right
as it turns out we identified that the
long reads were able to better extend
the contains and create longer contacts
in general
however because of the lower error rates
of our short reads we were able to
identify and assemble organisms that
were at lower depths of abundance in the
medical
to give you a brief overview of DNA
sequencing Technologies I picked five of
the most common Technologies and
compared them based on their read
lengths on the x-axis
the first two Sanger and 454 sequencing
are no longer used in the analysis of
DNA sequence mostly because they don't
provide additional benefits compared to
the other Technologies
Illumina short reads still provide
substantial benefits in terms of the
economy of cost and also have very low
error rates making them suitable for
variant calling examples
and the two latest Technologies from
Pacific biosciences or PAC bio and
Oxford nanotech introduce longer read
length than any of the prior
Technologies however this comes at
greater costs and have higher error
rates compared to the aluminum
technology typically
but I'd like to talk a little bit more
about the PAC bio Library prep and how
this can be used to correct for that
Achilles heel on the technology
so starting with a genomic read segment
at the Top If you will align if you go
through the normal Pac bio Library prep
you anneal two hairpin adapters on the
side to read effectively circularizing
it in a single strand
if you were to take one single sub read
or one single segment of the read and
sequence it you'd still have about a 14
to 17 error rate mostly through the
addition of index
however the Reed is circularized so if
you're able to read through the same
molecule multiple times given that it's
from the same molecule you can use all
of those leads to compare against each
other and create a consensus
and the Brilliance of this is that by
taking the same molecule you can
actually reduce the error rate lower
than one percent giving it parity with
the shorter B Technologies however not
abandoning the longer length of the Reed
in addition to this we also wanted to
generate some longer range information
and we typically use high C data in
order to generate this for metagenomes
IC is the use of cross-linked DNA within
individual cells and in this figure you
can see the cross-linking indicated by
the black bars
after you cross-link and share the
genome you can create sequencing
libraries that preserve this long-range
interaction and generate a data set for
you to use down the stream
using the statistical Association of
those in those Junctions you can
actually take contigs and Associate them
with the DNA that was predicted to be in
the same cell at the time of
cross-linking thereby been in contacts
into genomes
and the ultimate goal of both binning
and assembly is to create resources that
allow you to classify metagenomes and we
assess these through three different
criteria
the first is through the continuity of
the assembly which is the length of the
contigs themselves but we can also
assess completeness and potential
misassemblies by counting the number of
single copy genes that are expected to
be in each lineage based on the
proportion of those genes you can
estimate how complete a bacterial genome
assembly is
likewise if you find more than one copy
of a single copy Gene that indicates the
potential for and misassembly or the
inclusion of data that should not be
there in that genome
but there's another caveat and that is
microbial lineages within the metagenome
can be quite diverse and we're not often
able to to resolve them down to every
specific lineage
so if we take this dendrogram and we
divide it up based on taxonomy we
typically divide it based on the
percentage of sequence that's shared
amongst lineages and you can see that A
genus species and a strain are in
decreasing order in terms of their
resolution
in all practical purposes though when we
finally create our final set of bins
which are typically termed microbial
assembled genomes they are Composites of
the lineage and are often not resolved
down to the strain level so in many
cases a MAG may be a composite of a
species or even a Genus in the end
result
so I'd like to shift Focus now and talk
about our Fufu principle study and in
this study we wanted to do a full length
characterization of a single sample
taking a postmortem from a sheep and we
sequenced it with several different DNA
sequencing Technologies to incredible
depths and then assembled it using the
metafly assembly
to give you a sense for the amount of
data that we collected the primary DNA
sequencing technology was the generation
of pathfio Hi-Fi reads which were in
total about 255 billion bases of DNA
sequence or gigabases in addition to
this we generated Illumina short reads
for both read depth and polishing
purposes and we also generated high C
short reads for binning
and we wanted to ask what are the
explicit benefits of these low error
rate long reads in metal genome assembly
can they overcome the challenges that
we've identified
and we wanted to do an Apples to Apples
comparison because we realized we can't
really compare the unique benefits of
low error rate if we take different
samples and sequencing using different
Technologies so I think we found a
clever way around this to provide that
Apples to Apples comparison so in this
diagram I show a schematic of the pack
bio read in multiple sub reads
just as a reminder each of these
subreads is used to correct the read for
the final Hi-Fi data set so this entire
read is turned into one read in our
Hi-Fi data set
but I thought what if we could actually
get around the sampling bottles where if
we sample the same this if we sequence
the same sample multiple times we may
get different results
what if we took individual sub reads
from that same sequencing run and use
them as if they were uncorrected packed
bioeads this now allows us multiple
samples multiple low uncorrected reads
that we can use in our comparison
so what we did was we took each of those
data sets and assembled them using
metafly in order to compare against an
equivalent amount of uncorrected long
reads versus a an equivalent amount of
Hi-Fi corrected leads
but first I'd like to show you the Hi-Fi
assembly which was incredibly high
quality as you'd expect
we identified 49 closed Circle contacts
just from the initial assembly and this
was without any additional work or
analysis to generate them
you can see the larger hairball in the
middle of the graph and this turned out
to be an amalgamation of both eukaryotic
genomes which we didn't characterize in
in depth and also prokaryotic sequence
but you may also notice that there are
smaller circles in this graph and these
represent what I believe were found to
be satellite DNA such as plasmids
returning to our comparison of the CLR
assemblies I classified each of the
context based on its predicted taxonomic
affiliation based on Kingdom and you can
see here the plot of the total length of
the assembly in each of those categories
from viruses eukaryotes Archaea and
bacteria and also those were that were
unclassified in no hit category
in all cases except for the unclassified
category the Hi-Fi assembly had 10 to 35
percent more assembled sequence of that
super Kingdom
but it's not just longer amounts of DNA
sequence for each kingdom the height
file assembly was actually more complete
as well this is a graph of the
completeness of these contigs based on
the count of single copy genes anything
that's above 90 percent is considered to
be incredibly high quality draft GMS and
you can see from the Hi-Fi data set it's
over two-fold higher in greater than 90
completion than the other assemblies and
actually has the highest number of
connotines at this category than
anything else that's been published in
the literature today
so in order to improve this incredible
Foundation we use high C data to try to
create a final set of bins or mags from
these contacts
when we did so we found a very
interesting phenomenon and that was the
fact that when we compared the average X
coverage of short reads to each of our
bins
against the cumulative cumulative length
of our assembly we noticed a great
discrepancy so you'd expect that as the
assembly approaches the right hand side
of this graph it would actually increase
in length and the lower ends of the
graph would indicate that more less
abundant lineages are being assembled
and this was the case for the Hi-Fi
assembly we actually found that 16 of
the length of the Hi-Fi assembly was in
bins that had less than 5x coverage of
short reads
but does this mean that we're just
assembling a bunch of low abundant
species and they're not really resolved
very well and not very complete when we
take a look at our bins based on single
copy Gene completion at the ninth
greater than 90 category we actually
find a greater percentage of Hi-Fi reads
at less than 5x coverage than the CLR
data sets as well as several Hi-Fi bins
that have less than 1X coverage which
shows incredible quality of
distinguishing these lineages
so the question is are the CLR
assemblies just not assembling the low
abundant linkages it turns out we don't
think that that's the case and in this
bipartite graph I want to show a
comparison between the data set from
clr1 to our high five bins and in this
graph we're actually showing association
between bins from the CLR side to HiFi
that indicate that they may be
orthologous genome assemblies that have
been split based on Match distances
The Edge color indicates the number of
associations where purple indicates two
Hi-Fi bins for every one CLR bin whereas
yellow indicates three for every one CLR
beam
we've found across all three CLR data
sets there is an average of 12 CLR bins
that tended to be these collapsed
Assemblies of at least on average 25 26
Hi-Fi bins
but in particular I'd like to point out
one example that I think is very
instrumental in understanding why this
is occurring and this is for our yellow
Edge for CLR bin 451.
when we compare the assembly graph
generated by menifly it's quite clear
why this lineage is poorly resolved in
CLR this is the Hi-Fi assembly graph and
each of the Hi-Fi bins that were
Composites of this are labeled in
different colors with blue being Hi-Fi
been 451 orange 452 and green beam
471. you can see that even though they
have similar regions that result in the
connections between all three bins you
can sort of pull them apart yourself and
create each separate bin yourself
when we take a look at the same
composite CLR bin you can see why this
has all been condensed using CLR weeds
we were not able to distinguish between
those three distinct lineages and this
is primarily due to the error rate of
the reeds
when we align Hi-Fi reads to our Hi-Fi
bins we can also see a consistency in
reading the read depth is the blue bar
and the depth of coverage for each bin
was 10x 20x and 30X respectively for the
3x5 bins
how does this look in clr1 bin it's
highly variable and the the average
depth is around 45x which suggests that
this is indeed a composite of those
three bins
now keep in mind all four of these bins
were considered to be high completion
and low redundancy so it just goes to
show that this sort of resolution is
integral in actually distinguishing
between these lineages and not all high
quality bins are created equal
and this gave us great confidence in
using Hi-Fi reads for other sorts of
analysis and one particular area that we
thought that HiFi leads could provide
substantial benefit is in phasing
variants that we identify in the
sequence data phasing is the use of
Statistics or physical data in order to
link separate variants in our case we're
using the Hi-Fi reads themselves
and to illustrate this point this
diagram shows
two different read sets in both red and
blue that phase difference single
nucleotide polymorphisms at the top into
distinct haplotypes a haplotype is a
linked set of genetic variants that will
be passed on to descendant lineages and
we can actually distinguish these using
the Hi-Fi reads whereas it was far more
difficult to use short reads to be the
same
so we are the first group that attempted
to apply this to metagenomes and we've
created a tool called mag phase which
exclusively uses HiFi reads to identify
and distinguish haplotypes in
metagenomes
this is a table of the results from mag
phase and what we were able to find is
that mag face was capable of linking and
phasing variants up to 500 kilobases in
length which is a substantial proportion
of a typical bacterial genome size of
four megabases
but the most important values I'd like
you to uh
look at are the percentage of
polymorphic mags which had at least one
identifiable haplotype and our Hi-Fi
data set you can see that the majority
of our Hi-Fi data sets are HiFi mags do
not have polymorphic haplotypes that
could be discovered whereas in the CLR
data sets given all the data that I've
shown so far is consistent with them
being collapsed and condensed
representations of the metagenome and
had higher percentage polymorphic Mass
I'd also like to point out that in some
regions of certain mags there were high
degrees of polymorphic alleles
and we actually counted up to 25
alternate haplotype alleles in some
regions of Hi-Fi assembly this is double
in the same same or equivalent regions
in the CLR data sets again these were
Composites of Highly polymorphic regions
a picture is worth a thousand words so
our collaboratives at Pac bio helped us
in generating these igv plots and you
can see at the top in the the red circle
the thick red square that we actually
have depths of coverage of different
variant sites indicated by alternate
colors and these are clearly
distinguished within the Hi-Fi data you
can see the alternate allele is
patterned here and the references
pattern underneath and these are
appreciable depths of coverage that are
pretty consistent across the identified
variant sites
when we compare the same region in an
orthologous CLR lineage you can see the
picture gets occluded quite quickly
uh there are at least three different
alternative haplotypes that were
identified by mag phase and much of the
reason for this identification was a
high degree of heterogeneity in regions
upstream and downstream of the target
sites it was very difficult to
distinguish because of the high degree
of variance and the low resolution of
the sequence in this region to
distinguish between them
so in conclusion the complexities of
metagenome assembly are quite daunting
but the utility of knowing the
metagenome that has great impacts on
many different types of research
projects
we found that Hi-Fi reads provide
substantial benefits to Medicaid and
assembly and additional utility
and we've also identified the means by
which you can use Hi-Fi reads to phase
metagenome lineages through the
discovery of haplotypes and we are
planning to release the software through
publication fairly soon
and I'd like to acknowledge many of our
collaborators this is a large
collaborative effort particularly with
my colleagues at the USDA Tim Smith in
particular our colleagues at UC Davis in
particular Misha komogorov and Pablo
pack bio was incredibly instrumental in
the development of Mag phase and all of
our other Consortium collaborators
since I'm with the USDA I have to
provide a disclaimer the mentioning of
trade names or products is for
informational purposes only and the USDA
cannot endure specific products thank
you very much for your time and I'd be
happy to take your questions